i feel just sick to my stomach like i've
got food poisoning that's how it happens
for me sort of see things your brain
would just
distort things
my obsession about it
changed everything
not for the better
hi i'm tim i'm 29 and i've been dealing
with ocd for 21 years when we were
diagnosed with the eating disorder when
i was 24
i'm said i was always pretty anxious kid
the anxiety
was terrible
to keep people from dying it'd be
flicking on light switches tapping feet
getting dressed and undressed it used to
take me 45 minutes to get
dressed it's a rabbit hole you'll
just get stuck and then you can't really
move on until you feel like that
compulsion has been completed
to your mind's satisfaction
they weren't sure they thought it might
be adhd at one stage but i think they
sort of
came to the conclusion that it was ocd
my ocd thoughts turned to body image
issues when i was 21 years old the
thoughts sort of came around
i had my 21st with one of my best mates
and we got the photos back from that and
i just i looked at the photos
and i just i didn't like what i saw
there was comments about my body and
stuff like that
and i guess because of my obsessive
nature i kind of
became obsessed about sort of what was
said
it spiked pretty quickly in a six month
period there was it was noticeable that
there was something wrong
having to go through the thoughts of
eating that meal i just wouldn't get
hungry
and then there was other behaviors there
was chuck food out when people weren't
looking purging
my brother
he couldn't look at me
[Music]
yeah
nothing i think he ended up crying
[Music]
going to a hospital the psychiatrist
kind of said yeah it's time to come in
here
your organs are starting to struggle
the brain fog i just stand there
trying to do a crossword good luck
read a book good luck
all i can do is probably just lie down
and sleep most of the time
so i was in i was in
different clinics in different day
programs during
a four-year five-year period i was the
only male the only male in all of them
very depressing very very lonely time
you can have
as many people around your support
network can be as
as
great as anything
but it's still a lonely lonely journey
i started on my road to recovery when i
was 26.
as you learn techniques
to help with your anxiety and sort of
and you you believe that you want to get
better that's the main thing
you have to want to get better
and i still i still deal with it it's
not like
i come out of a
clinic and you're 100 better i'll
probably fight this for the rest of my
life
i don't think there's there's a cure for
ocd
um
it's something you manage
someone explained it to me like managing
diabetes
i wasn't able to work for a while quite
a few number of years but luckily now
i'm in a healthier body
so i currently work for an ndis company
in newcastle
i can't help
other people
if i don't
tell my experiences
that's the main reason i want to speak
out so if there's other men
experiencing these these issues
i can help them
i get out most weekends playing golf
about to become an uncle
so that's my main priority now and
getting better
if you've been triggered by anything
today and you want to get some help and
additional information you can hit the
link below